[Music]
we've been so excited for Avengers
infinity war to come out that Avengers 4
is kind of taking a backseat to it but
there have been some leaked photos and
theories around them lately so I thought
we'd take this video to talk about it
sorry infinity war we still love you
before we get started if you're new to
my channel be sure to hit that subscribe
button
and if you don't the big rumor going
around about Avengers 4 is that it's
going to be a time travel movie as you
can see here from the leaked photos we
have Captain America the Hulk ant-man
and Tony Stark we're not sure if any of
the other Avengers go back in time but
we know that this group does thanks to
these photos okay so at this point
you're probably thinking okay they use
the time stone to go back in time right
wrong okay so technically it could
happen in the movie but it's very
unlikely the main reason why it's very
unlikely to happen is because in the
trailers that have been released we've
seen evany ma captured dr. strange
doesn't exactly show the eye of agamotto
in the trailer but you can see the
necklace that is used to hold it
evany ma is in thanasis black order or
as they're being called in the movie the
children of Thanos in the comics Thanos
has the children of Thanos go retrieve
the Infinity stones for him it seems
like this will be the same in the movie
and therefore by deductive reasoning we
can conclude that Emma dima takes the
time stone from Doctor Strange but
besides the fact that the Avengers
probably won't have the time stone to
travel back in time
there's been another cool discovery if
you look closely at the hands of Ant Man
Captain America and Tony Stark you'll
notice an interesting bracelet that
they're wearing these bracelets are
believed to be the technology they use
in order to travel back through time so
now the question is where did these
bracelets come from if you look closely
you'll notice that Tony Stark is
actually wearing some sort of shield
uniform the shield's create this
technology and then give it to Tony
Stark not likely and Tony Stark is
usually more technologically advanced
than shield anyways so let's rule that
one out
I think the most likely theory and my
personal belief is that Pym tech
actually created this technology ant-man
and the wasp come out between Avengers
infinity war and Avenger
which is the perfect time to introduce
this technology also ant-man and the
wasp is supposed to deal with
interdimensional travel in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so it makes sense
that Pym tech would invent this
technology and also if you look closely
you can see that Tony Stark
and Captain America are wearing
bracelets whereas ant-man's device is
infused in as glove this is an indicator
that this time travel technology is
introduced to us an ant-man and the wasp
which is why it's embedded in his glove
these are just some of the theories
about how the Avengers could go back in
time it's clear that they go back in
time judging by the outfits that they're
wearing
you can notice Tony rocking that black
sabbath's shirt that he wore in the
original Avengers movie you can also
notice Captain America rocking his
original outfit and not as Nomad outfit
in infinity war and he's got a big shiny
shield that hasn't been damaged yet also
the background looks like New York which
is where the big fight scene took place
in the first Avengers movie maybe
they're going back there so they can go
through the portal that the tesseract or
the space stone opens up so they can
attack Thanos before he's wearing the
Infinity Gauntlet what do you guys think
you think they're going back to fight
Thanos do you think they're going back
because somebody died in infinity war
let me know in the comments below I'd
love to interact with you and hear some
of your theories be sure to give this
video a thumbs up and be a really good
friend and subscribe to my channel you
stay classy Wolfgang wolf wolf
you